und jetzt das heute journal
müller in der 81 minute
es hätte also auch anders laufen können
so leicht kann sport hoffnungen über ron
guten abend auch einer der fußball für
eine hysterische überschätzte unnötig
teure nebensache hielte müsste
akzeptieren dass in deutschland von
diesen nachrichten tag vor allem eins im
gedächtnis bleiben wird die niederlage
im wembley-stadion die nicht unbedingt
unvermeidlich war
tränen sind durchaus erlaubt denn
traurig darf man schon sein nach diesem
bitteren aus in wembley nach diesem
bitteren ausscheiden gegen england
[Musik]
der ausgeglichene spielt
alle mannschaften haben sich ein
bisschen neutralisiert
dementsprechend bitter ist
die vorfreude ist groß auf diesen
fußball klassiker der mit einer ganz
starken gäste beider mannschaften
beginnt ein kollektiver kniefall als
zeichen gegen rassismus und für toleranz
starke gesten starkes spiel erste chance
für england sterling scheiterte auf der
anderen seite toller pass von ph werts
auf timo werner große chance nicht
genutzt das hätte die führung sein
können vielleicht sogar müssen manche
konnten da kaum noch hinschauen haben
dann müssen wir mal so eiskalt als 90
seiten haben auf eine chance zu nutzen
chancen gibt es auch nach dem
seitenwechsel klar wer mit diesem
harmlosen abschluss fordert john pequod
zu dieser furiosen parade wenig
torabschlüssen im strafraum das ändert
sich in der 75 minute pass von chong ins
zentrum dass 100 england führt der
torschütze wohin steuert die erfasst mit
diesem schlimmen fehlpass auch für den
ausgleich zumindest mitverantwortlich
gewesen wäre wenn thomas müller
und da geht der konjunktiv weiter
getroffen hätte unfassbar
das ist ja fast schon wie ein fluch
thomas müller damit auch weiter ohne ein
einziges wm tor besser machte es harry
caine der kurz vor dem abpfiff den
schlusspunkt setzt england schlägt
deutschland mit 2 zu 0 ein wirklich
tolles spiel von dem einige erst später
erfahren werden wie groß war
nils kaben hat das spiel am ort
miterlebt nils wenn man alles gesehen
hat musste diese niederlage sein
kommt drauf an wie man das betrachten
will fragt man halt die engländer die
hier gerade ganz glücklich nach hause
gegangen sind dann sagen sie ja das
wurde allerhöchste zeit denn schließlich
hat die deutsche mannschaft nach 66 alle
wichtigen spiele gegen england geworden
gucken wir auf das spiel heute abend
dann war die chance von thomas müller
der moment wo das spiel noch eine andere
richtung hätte nehmen können
er hat vorher er selbst hat vorher im
trainingslager gesagt das wird ganz ganz
knapp und wir müssen jede chance die
sich bietet das werden sich viele seien
nutzen das haben sie nicht gemacht
zweieinhalb möglichkeiten gab es und
deshalb ja dann musste das heute abend
mal so kommen nun müssen wir am ende
dieser ära mal grundsätzlich werden was
muss hansi flick von heute abend und was
davor war lernen und jetzt ändern
naja das ist jetzt wer würde jetzt den
rahmen ein bisschen springen dabei hansi
flick könnte zum beispiel wieder so ein
bisschen mehr begeisterung in diese
mannschaft bringen dass wir mit gerissen
werden so wie es die dänen vor gemacht
haben oder die schweizer gestern unsere
auftritte waren alle in ordnung dass
portugal spieler ein bisschen heraus
aber der rest war doch sehr viel ruhiges
behäbiges verwalten
da fehlte so der funke übergesprungen
das wenn er das schafft sowie erst beim
fc bayern in letzter zeit hinbekommen
hat dann hätte ich schon viel gewonnen
und dann haben wir viel spaß bei der wm
in einem jahr
und jemand will sie touristen dankeschön
alles gute sollte heute abend so frisch
danach steht unverschämt groß irgendwie
so eine 8 im raum das ausscheiden schon
im achtelfinale
also deprimierend früh da fehlt
natürlich der abstand um die erde als
ganzes zu sehen boris büchler unternimmt
den versuch den neunten bundestrainer
einigermaßen gerecht zu werden da war ja
auch schönes endstation wembley stadion
für den bundestrainer heißt es in london
bei buy
nach 100 98 länderspielen eine amtszeit
mit tiefen krisen aber auch großen
erfolgen
[Applaus]
rio 2014 wm triumph der höhepunkt der
ära löw
wir sind alle weltmeister
alles beginnt 2006 klinsmann hört nach
der wm auf und er wird sein nachfolger
das tief und uns oliver bierhoff andy
köpke meines und ich denke auch der
gesamten dfb-spitze dass wir
europameister werden wollen
ob bei seiner ersten europameisterschaft
2008 oder bei seiner letzten 2021 der
weg führte nie zum em titel
der erste große tiefpunkt der ära löw
2018 erstmals scheidet ein deutsches
team bei einer wm schon in der vorrunde
aus nach der blamage in russland bekommt
der heftigen gegenwind macht aber weiter
doch der neuanfang des linc nach der 0 6
gegen spanien ende 2020 gibt es massiven
rücktrittsforderungen
im märz kündigte an seinen rücktritt an
will seine letzte mission zu einem
erfolgreichen abschluss bringen doch
daraus wurde nichts heute ein bitterer
abgang das schlusskapitel unter seiner
regie
unabhängig vom ein oder anderen sieg
oder einer niederlage habe ich in dieser
zeit viel lernen können und menschen
kennengelernt die mir echt wichtig waren
die mir sehr viel geholfen haben und die
mir heute natürlich sehr sehr wichtig in
meinem leben sind dessen erfahrungen die
ich nicht missen möchte
rückschläge und tiefpunkte haben die
endphase seines wirkens als
bundestrainer geprägt doch blickt man
auf die gesamten 15 jahre
so hatte dem deutschen fussball auch
viel gegeben und damit erstmal genug von
einem sport in dem ein 23 punkte
alles entscheidend zu einem geschehen in
dem es genauso ist wirtschaft und
finanzen
zwei prozent inflation auf deutsch
geldentwertung und bank zinsen die ein
bisschen drüber liegen das galt mal als
gesund aber das war einmal eine
regierung die zulässt dass gespart es
nichts mehr bringt und gleichzeitig
geldentwertung jedes jahr 23 prozent des
gesparten auffrisst wird irgendwann ins
schleudern kommen in der inflationsrate
liegt sprengstoff und die rate liegt
jetzt bei 2,3 prozent
offiziell es ist nicht nur ein gefühl
die frischen blumen vom markt oder das
brot vom bäcker vieles ist zuletzt
teurer geworden
die händler geben ihre höheren kosten an
die kunden weiter die rohstoffe für die
backwaren
man hat zwar was in der kasse aber im
endeffekt was unterm strich übrig bleibt
ist natürlich etwas weniger die heute
veröffentlichten daten bestätigen das
waren und dienstleistungen kosteten im
juni 20 21 2,3 prozent mehr als vor
einem jahr
damit bleibt die inflation
vergleichsweise hoch trotz eines
leichten rückgangs
das ist insofern ein jahr der korrektur
im nächsten jahr werden wir da wieder
normales fahrwasser hinein gelangen
alles also halb so wild selbst die
bundesbank hält eine inflation von
zwischenzeitlich vier prozent für
möglich
nicht jeder preisanstieg lässt sich
darauf zurückführen doch corona die
märkte durcheinander gewirbelt dazu
kommen lieferengpässe wie in der
baubranche stahl holz und anderes
material so teuer wie lange nicht
extrem gestiegen auch die kosten für
energie öl und gas sind um 9 4 prozent
teurer geworden
das spüren die verbraucher auch an der
tankstelle hier schlägt zudem die co2
abgabe zu buche auch flüge und reisen
sind zuletzt teurer geworden und wer im
urlaub ein auto mieten will muss tief in
die tasche greifen preisaufschläge von
weit über 100 prozent keine seltenheit
es ist klar die autovermieter mit so
einem schlechten jahr wie es letztes
jahr hat man auch mit so einem
schwierigen jahr was sie dieses jahr
haben sie müssen halt irgendwie sehen
dass wenigstens ein bisschen bleibt rein
kommt ein auf und ab so unkalkulierbar
für manche experten hat corona damit
eine entwicklung befeuert wie es sie in
der deutschen wirtschaftsgeschichte
bisher nicht gegeben hat wir können
nicht sicher sein was da passiert aber
wir sehen am aktuellen rand dass die
engpässe enorm sind sie sind so groß wie
das noch nie gemessen wurde und es wäre
sehr überraschend wenn daraus nicht
steigende preise resultieren würden
die angst vor der inflation sie kommt
immer wieder auf
doch corona hat sie spürbar werden
lassen die nachrichten von gundula gause
die bundeswehr hat ihren einsatz in
afghanistan beendet nach fast 20 jahren
die letzten noch im feldlager masar i
scharif stationierten deutschen soldaten
sind auf dem rückflug nach deutschland
die usa hatten auf einen abzug der
truppen bis zum vierten juli gedrängt
ein österreichischer
medienwissenschaftler hat der grünen
kanzlerkandidaten baerbock vorgeworfen
einige passagen in ihrem buch
abgeschrieben zu haben
in ihrer publikation jetzt wie wir unser
land erneuern gebe es mehrere deutliche
parallelen zu anderen veröffentlichungen
ein grünen sprecher wies die vorwürfe
als absurd zurück das sei der versuch
von rufmord bei den beschriebenen
passagen handele es sich um allgemein
zugängliche fakten oder bekannte grüne
positionen auch der verlag sieht keine
urheberrechtsverletzungen
während der ersten beiden pandemie
wellen sind in deutschen pflegeheimen
mehr menschen gestorben als im vergleich
zu vorjahreszeiträumen der aok
pflegereport beschreibt einen anstieg
der todesfälle im frühjahr vergangenen
jahres um 20 prozent im herbst dann um
zudem wurde die situation der
pflegebedürftigen untersucht mehr als 70
prozent gaben an sich einsam und
isoliert gefühlt zu haben
die außen und entwicklungsminister der
g-20-staaten haben über möglichkeiten
einer besser abgestimmten
internationalen zusammenarbeit im kampf
gegen die pandemie beraten
im süditalienischen matera kritisierte
außenminister maß die impfstoff
diplomatie von russland und china
sie dürften corona vakzine nicht nur
verteilen um kurzfristige politische
vorteile zu erlangen
außerdem berieten die minister über
maßnahmen in klimaschutz und zur
bekämpfung des hungers in afrika sehr
sehr nötig dass während europa warnungen
in den wind schlägt und zb in
fußballstadien und auf public viewing
plätzen tut als wäre corona längst
vorbei erleben menschen auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent den aufprall
einer weiteren noch schlimmeren welle
allein vorletzte woche stieg die zahl
der neu infektionen und der todesfälle
um 40% 40 prozent steigerung in einer
woche weiten teilen des kontinents steht
das schlimmste noch bevor berichtet
unsere afrika korrespondentin sandra
teils menschen fliehen vor der polizei
szenen aus ugandas hauptstadt kampala
seit ein paar tagen gilt ein strenger
lockdown die meisten geschäfte mussten
schließen straßenhändler dürfen nicht
arbeiten
viele tun es trotzdem aus der not heraus
wir bekommen keinerlei hilfe wir haben
nichts um unsere familien zu ernähren
gar nichts deshalb sind wir hier
die polizei nimmt zahlreiche personen
fest
der lock down ist ein verzweifelter
versuch die kogit lage unter kontrolle
zu bekommen
in den vergangenen wochen sind die neuen
funktionen rapide gestiegen von unter
100 auf etwa 1700 am tag
die dunkelziffer ist erheblich höher
im größten öffentlichen krankenhaus
werden betten und sauerstoff knapp
wir bekommen patienten die wirklich
schwer krank sind sauerstoff therapie
brauchen und manche die kurz vor dem
organversagen stehen in afrika bietet
die dritte welle die zahlen der
infektion und toten auf dem kontinent
wirken im vergleich niedrig doch sie
drücken
so starben in afrika offiziell gut
140.000 menschen an dem virus
experten vermuten aber dass die meisten
kurve toten gar nicht als solche gezählt
werden weil viel zu wenig getestet wird
allein in südafrika starben offiziell
über 60.000 menschen wie hoch die zahlen
wirklich sind lässt die über
sterblichkeit an
sie liegt in südafrika bei über 150
tausend toten im moment treibt die delta
variante die infektionszahlen wieder in
die höhe
wir befinden uns im griff einer
verheerenden welle die allen anzeichen
nach schlimmer sein wird als die die ihr
vorausgegangen sind
einen harten lockdown kann sich
südafrika nicht leisten so ist weiterhin
fast alles offen nur die gastronomie
trifft es hat seit gestern darf es nur
noch geliefert werden der verkauf von
alkohol ist verboten
wenn die regierung es nicht schafft
genug impfstoff bereit zu stellen dann
ist die zukunft sehr sehr düster vor
allem für unsere branche
doch nicht nur südafrika der ganze
kontinent hängt beim impfen hoffnungslos
hinterher
gerade mal gut ein prozent der afrikaner
haben laut wifo vollen impfschutz der
kampf gegen cupid lässt sich so nicht
gewinnen
und wir schauen noch auf wetterphänomene
eine extreme hitzewelle hat die
westküste von nordamerika fest im griff
im kanadischen british columbia wurde
mit 47,9 grad celsius ein neuer rekord
aufgestellt auch in den usa rekordwerte
portland oregon kämpft mit über 45 grad
celsius und herab kühlungs zentren für
die bürger geschaffen
bis zum wochenende warnen die behörden
vor hitze und trockenheit
hierzulande haben schwere unwetter mit
starkregen und sturmböen viele regionen
getroffen vor allem im südwesten in
stuttgart standen straßen und häuser
unter wasser
die feuerwehr war über 330 mal im
einsatz an der staatsoper riss der sturm
teile des dachs weg auch in rottweil
verursachten starkregen und hagel
schäden und das wetter bleibt
unbeständig auch morgen muss mit
gewittern und kräftigem regen gerechnet
werden zum teil auch mit unwettern vor
allem im norden und im westen nur im
südosten bleibt es meist freundlich bei
17 bis 25 grad am donnerstag noch sehr
wechselhaft bei 16 bis nur 22 grad
danach beruhigt sich das wetter
allmählich bei bis zu 26 grad morgen
winkte ein freier tag und damit winkt
uns ein pünktliches runde mit ihnen
kommen sie bitte auch 21 uhr 45
[Musik]